Der Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Was ist eigentlich los im FIFA-Prozess? Da gibt es jetzt ein paar Neuigkeiten und die wollen wir besprechen mit The Only One, Jürgen Kalwa, mit dem wir schon das Tribünengespräch aufgenommen haben. Jetzt hier im Rasenfunk-Kurzpass. Jürgen, sei mir sehr herzlich gegrüßt.
Hi.
Nach Giesing, ja sehr gut. Sehr gut, du bist einfach wie immer hervorragend vorbereitet. Das wissen wir alle noch, denn wir zwei haben ja zusammen das Tribünengespräch aufgenommen zum FIFA-Prozess, das ja doch durchaus einigen Anklang gefunden hat. Warst du zufrieden mit der Resonanz?
Also wenn ich ganz ehrlich bin, ich hatte ja null Ahnung, wie erfolgreich der Rasenfunk ist. Also ich habe mir so etwas ausgemalt, weil es gibt niemanden, der über dich schlecht redet. Also das ist ja mein Medikator. Also niemanden, den ich kenne. Und das gibt dir nicht die Idee, wie ist die Reichweite. Also das war erstaunlich. Also meine Messlatte war jetzt hauptsächlich Twitter. Und da kam das auch, glaube ich, sehr stark rüber. Und das auch noch in Phasen. Also es gab eben die frischen Hörer, die immer am neuesten dran sind und sich gemeldet haben. Und dann gab es so die mit Verzögerung arbeiten, die natürlich bei so einem irrenlangen Projekt sich auch die Zeit gut zurechtlegen mussten, damit sie da durchkommen. Aber die dann eben mit Verspätung melden. Also ich hab's gehört. Und der Grad der Zufriedenheit über die Art und Weise, wie wir beide das irgendwie ausbreiten konnten, das war schon eine Überraschung. Weil ich sehe auch immer, dass das Thema schwierig ist. Also schwierig zu erklären, schwierig zu beschreiben und nicht so sehr. Aber auch die Sportwelt ist voll von diesen Heroisierungsbemühungen und den eher unkritischen Ansätzen. Und auch das ist ja hier anders bei dem Thema. Man muss ja wirklich eine Haltung haben und die dann auch durch exerzieren. Und dass es dafür ein starkes Interesse gibt, das war mir so nicht vertraut. Also da bin ich zu sehr auch in meiner eigenen Blase, wenn ich das noch anfügen darf. Ich arbeite ja nun ständig auch für Publikationen wie die FAZ und die NZZ und den Deutschlandfunk, das Radio und die Kollegen dort sind sehr offen für solche Themen und ich kann da sehr viel machen. Aber das würde ich jetzt erstmal nicht verallgemeinern wollen. Ich habe da nicht so viel gutes Feedback, was bei mir ankommt.
Ja, das freut mich sehr, ich war auch wie immer sehr angetan von den Hörern und Hörern. Es gibt immer die zwei Fraktionen, du hast es ja schon genannt. Erstmal ist es immer Wahnsinn, wie schnell Leute die Folge nach Veröffentlichung weggehört haben. Manchmal auch schneller als die Folge gedauert hat, da weiß man dann, ah, das ist jemand, der hört mit erhöhter Geschwindigkeit, gibt es ja viel im Podcast-Bereich. Ich konsumiere meine Podcasts inzwischen auch nur noch so.
Was ist denn so die Tempo-Quote?
Das mache ich immer von den Sprechen abhängig. Es gibt Podcasts, die höre ich tatsächlich auf zweifacher Geschwindigkeit, das sind sehr langsame Sprecher. Und es gibt aber auch Podcasts, die höre ich auf 1,7 und englische Podcasts in der Regel auf 1,5.
Okay, also ein guter Tipp für Leute, die sowas auch mal machen möchten.
Ja, also kann ich sehr empfehlen. Man muss sich ein bisschen dran gewöhnen und am Anfang war das auch gar nicht so meins. Aber inzwischen ist es unglaublich, weil ich halt so schaffe, eine Masse am Podcast wegzuhören, die ich sonst nie im Leben hören könnte. Und ja, das ist ein Gefühl des Souveränitäts. Aber was ich ja eigentlich sagen wollte, ist wirklich toll, wie schnell die Leute sind. Und genau das, was du gesagt hast, mit das ich noch ein paar Wochen später auch nochmal welche über Twitter melde. Das freut mich auch immer, weil das ist ja auch der Sinn dieser Tribünengespräche. Deswegen haben wir da so unglaublich viel Zeit reingesteckt in die Vorbereitung und in das Aufnehmen. Und das wird auch noch jetzt in den kommenden Wochen und Monaten immer mal wieder so weitergehen. Also ich habe jetzt noch Leute, die mich auf zwei Jahre alte Sendungen ansprechen. Und das ist ein wirklich tolles Gefühl, weil das hat man auch sonst sehr selten, finde ich.
Aber kannst du ein Geheimnis verraten und sagen, was ist die Reichweite jetzt von diesem einen Tribünengespräch gewesen?
Also die Reichweite ist genau im Durchschnitt. Wir haben 20.000 Downloads. Stand heute, 5. September. Das sind jetzt nur die, die über den Fides gehört haben. Bei Spotify haben es 2.000 Leute gehört. Und YouTube habe ich jetzt gerade nicht mehr vor Augen. Ich glaube, da waren es aber 3.000 oder so was. Also insgesamt, wenn ich mich jetzt gerade nicht verzerrt habe, 25.000. Und das ist eigentlich auch so der Durchschnitt, den wir haben. Das wird jetzt aber über die kommenden Wochen halt kontinuierlich wachsen, weil die Tribünengespräche erfreulicherweise immer gehört werden. Also anders als die Schlusskonferenzen, die werden ja auch alt. Aber genau, 3.000 Views hat es auf YouTube.
Okay, dann kann ich vielleicht, um diese Zahl ein bisschen zu bebildern, verraten, dass ich auch mal in Giesing gelebt habe. Und deshalb weiß, wo das Stadion an der Grünwalder Straße steht. Und ich stelle mir gerade so vor, das ist ungefähr die Menge von Leuten, die in so einem Stadion wie dem Stadion an der Grünwalder Straße Platz hätten. Wenn man die da hinkriegen würde und so eine Veranstaltung machen könnte, wäre auch nicht schlecht.
Gut, vor allem, wer weiß, wie hoch die Zahl wirklich ist. Gefühlt war sie ehrlich gesagt höher. Ich hätte jetzt gedacht, ich habe jetzt auch gerade erst auf die Statistiken geguckt, gefühlt hätte ich gesagt, irgendwas in den 30.000. Aber eigentlich geht es ja um die Zahl nicht. Es ist ja eher nur so ein netter Indikator. Und die Masse an Feedback finde ich immer interessanter. Vielleicht werden wir jetzt eh schon über das Tribünengespräch sprechen. Kann ich da noch zwei Dinge sagen? Eine Sache, die mir sehr leid tut. Ich habe Body Shaming hinsichtlich Chuck Blazer betrieben und zwar zu doll. Vermutlich habe ich da einfach überkompensiert, wie viel ich über ihn gelesen hatte, was er da Schlechtes getan hat rund um den Fußball. Das wäre allerdings kein Grund gewesen, da so... Anscheinend habe ich da nicht den richtigen Ton gefunden zwischen eine Bebilderung. Also ich habe ihn ja, glaube ich, den Weihnachtsmann genannt mit dem... Ah, jetzt weiß ich gerade gar nicht mehr, was meine Analogie war. Aber anscheinend habe ich da den Ton nicht richtig getroffen. Das tut mir leid. Das haben ein paar Hörerinnen und Hörer geschrieben. Und da habt ihr recht. Das sollte nicht so sein. Und wir haben anscheinend auch nicht klar genug gemacht. Das kam später im Podcast, aber wir wussten schon, dass er tot war. Also das haben wir auch einige Kommentatoren geschrieben. Das kam irgendwann bei Stunde zwei oder Stunde drei. Und wir haben es aber nicht am Anfang auch schon gesagt. Also das war uns auch beiden bewusst, dass er nicht mehr am Leben war, als wir aufgenommen haben. Beides wollte ich noch kurz sagen.
Ja, und wenn ich das dann hinzufügen darf, dass er gestorben ist, ist gar nicht unwichtig. Er hat eine Rolle gespielt in der investigativen Arbeit, der des FBI und der Staatsanwaltschaft. Er hat dann auch gestanden, also vor einem anderen Richter, aber im selben Verfahrensgang. Er hat also bestimmte Straftaten zugegeben und hätte theoretisch bestraft werden müssen. Teil eins, weil er gestorben ist, wurde er nicht bestraft. Teil zwei, all das an Material, was durch seine Hilfe mit in diese Ermittlungen eingeführt werden konnte, konnte so nicht einfach in den Prozess, der im November, Dezember stattgefunden hat, eingesetzt werden, weil das amerikanische Rechtsverständnis für Prozesse so ist. Man braucht immer auch einen Menschen hinter irgendeinem Stück Papier oder einem Tondokument. Und wenn der dann nicht als Zeuge antreten kann, weil er eben nicht mehr lebt, dann fällt der auch aus. Das heißt, an einem frühen, zu einem frühen Zeitpunkt hatte man ein bisschen die Angst, dass, also die Tatsache, dass er und ja auch schon andere gestorben waren, die Situation der Ermittler schwächt im Prozess. Die Sorge war da. Das hat sich aber dann erledigt, weil die haben doch wirklich jede Menge andere Zeugen und Materialien auftreiben können und dadurch wurden halt dann in diesem Fall die drei Angeklagten, zwei von ihnen wurden halt in mehreren Fällen für schuldig befunden und nur einer wurde freigesprochen.
Genau, da werden wir gleich noch ausführlicher darüber sprechen. Das ist ein ganz wichtiges Thema. Alle Prozessbeobachter haben da somit die größte Sorge, dass die Behörden zu langsam arbeiten würden, eben weil jetzt schon mehrere Kronzeugen gestorben sind, verstorben sind. Und zum anderen noch mal ganz kurz, worum es im FIFA-Prozess geht. Also es sind insgesamt 42 Beschuldigte angeklagt, der Korruption, der Bestechung und der organisierten, bandenartigen Kriminalität. Das ist insofern wichtig, weil es dann unter einem Mafia-Gesetz behandelt werden kann, dieser Prozess. Wenn euch das dahinter interessiert, müsst ihr das Tribünengespräch hören. Jetzt hier im Kurzpass können wir nicht nochmal das alles auftröseln. Das wäre jetzt zu viel. Wahrscheinlich hast du auch kurz nochmal Schnappatmung bekommen. Jetzt müssen wir wieder in das andere Riesendokument zurückküpfen. Nein, müssen wir nicht. Also der FIFA-Prozess geht eben um Bestechung und wird in den USA ausgefochten und da bist du eben auch vor Ort, Jürgen. Und du warst jetzt auch beim Prozess selbst an einem der Tage mindestens vor Ort. Kannst du uns mal schildern, wie ist denn die Atmosphäre da gewesen?
Ja, ich habe mir den Tag ausgesucht, an dem die Strafe für den Paraguayer Naputh ausgesprochen wurde. Unter anderem auch aus rein arbeitstaktischen Gründen, wenn man lange Tage in einem Gericht rum sitzt und am Ende doch nichts wirklich daraus machen kann für eine nachrichtliche journalistische Geschichte, dann tut einem auch ein bisschen die Zeit weh. Und hier wusste ich einfach, wenn ich da jetzt hinfahre früh morgens und wichtig ist, dass ich einen Platz bekomme im Gerichtssaal, dann kann ich das alles verfolgen und dann habe ich auch nachher das Material, um etwas daraus zu berichten. Und das habe ich dann auch getan, Deutschlandfunk noch am selben Tag in der FAZ, dann einen Tag später.
Muss man sich da akkreditieren, weil du gesagt hast, ob du noch einen Platz bekommst oder ist das First-Come-First-Serve?
Genau, das ist es, weil der Raum, vielleicht fange ich mal da an, den zu beschreiben. Also wir reden erstmal von einem modernen Gerichtsgebäude, nicht so ein altes Münchner Amtsgericht oder Landgericht. Das 150 Jahre auf dem Buckel hat, sowas gibt es hier natürlich auch, aber ganz verglast, modern und so weiter. Und auch die Sitzungssäle, sehr, sehr modern und gradlinig, quasi quadratig, mit einer hohen Decke, war völlig überrascht, aber da kommt viel natürliches Licht rein. Die Technik ist da, Mikrofontechnik war nicht super, aber sehr hilfreich, weil sonst hätte man kaum jemanden richtig gut verstehen können.
Sind die Räume da so groß?
Also, wie viele Leute sind da rein? Ich würde sagen, halbes Basketballfeld von der Grundfläche. In dem Fall eine Richterin, Pamela Chen, aber sonst würden wir ja von Richter sprechen, relativ nah an der Wand auf der anderen Seite und die Zuschauerbänke eben auf der Seite, wo der Eingang zum Raum ist. Allerdings nur so fünf Reihen und da passen Reihen, würde ich mal sagen, vielleicht 50 Leute, 55 Leute. Und deshalb muss man schauen. Zum Glück war jetzt aus bestimmten Mediengründen dieser Termin nicht mehr ganz so interessant, weil wir eine Woche vorher einen Termin hatten, bei dem die erste heftige Strafe ausgesprochen wurde und das war ein Termin, zu dem ich es dann nicht geschafft habe, obwohl ich auch dorthin gehen wollte. Das war der Brasilianer Marin, José Maria Marin, der vier Jahre bekommen hat. Das wäre aber dann so ähnlich gewesen, also mit leicht anderer Besetzung. Natürlich dieselbe Richterin, natürlich die selben Staatsanwälte, andere Verteidiger, andere Angeklagte und andere Verwandte. Und zum Beispiel Naputh hatte sehr, sehr viele direkte Verwandte mit im Saal. Und zwar die Frau, die einen deutschstämmigen Hintergrund hat, die auch selber eine Aussage noch gemacht hat, die vier Kinder waren da, das sind ältere Kinder, mit den angeheirateten Partnern. Und ich hatte auch noch den ein oder anderen Freund, nicht einfach zu identifizieren, die hatten nun keine paraguayanische Flagge mitgebracht oder sowas. Und die Journalisten, also dann war jemand von der FIFA da, der hat sich auch nicht identifiziert, es war jemand vom Konkerkaft da, es war jemand von Konwebol da, also die Organisation, die also als sogenannte Opfer dieser ganzen Straftaten sich nun gerieren, die hatten nun jemanden geschickt. Johnny Infantino, der am Tag vorher bei Trump gewesen ist, war nicht da, ich habe auch nicht damit gerechnet, dass er kommt, aber es wäre natürlich witzig gewesen, dass sich jemand als der Sachwalter von solchen wichtigen Dingen vielleicht in irgendeiner Weise persönlich zeigt. Das war nicht der Fall. Eine Gruppe von Journalisten, vielleicht zehn, vielleicht zwölf, stark südamerikanisch, lateinamerikanisch geprägt, ich habe nicht mit allen gesprochen, sondern mit ein paar, und die hatten alle auch Erfahrung mit dem Stoff, die waren jetzt nicht einfach nur so mal reingeschneit, die kannten sich aus.
Aber es bildet das auch so ein bisschen ab, wie in den Medien über diesen Prozess berichtet wird. Also er ist ja dadurch, dass er US-basiert ist, wird wahrscheinlich das US-amerikanische Interesse groß sein und dadurch, dass die Beteiligten jetzt aus den Konfederationen Südamerikas kommen und zum Teil Lateinamerikas, kommt dann eben da auch daher ein Fokus. Aber wie würdest du die Berichterstattung über diesen Prozess beschreiben? Ist das ein großes Thema, würdest du jetzt sagen, die Journalistenzahl, die du da vor Ort gefunden hast, ist eine hohe oder ist eine normale oder ist es vielleicht auch gar nicht mehr so das große Thema?
Nee, also inneramerikanisch nicht. Also zum Beispiel Ken Bensinger, der ja sehr viel Zeit verbracht hat in diesem Gerichtssaal vorher, bevor er dann sein Buch geschrieben hat, der war zum Beispiel nicht da. Hab ich auch nicht erwartet, weil der lebt in Los Angeles. Also der kann nun auch nicht wegen jeder Kleinigkeit mal eben nach New York fliegen und das muss ja jemand bezahlen. Wir reden hier in so einer Phase davon, dass wir halt mehrere Nachrichtenagenturen da haben. Also AFP ist da, also Agence France-Press und AP, Associated Press ist da und so. Und damit kriegt es natürlich auch dann so das Megafon, den Megafoneffekt in den Rest der Welt hinaus. Und dann je nachdem, wer sich für sowas interessiert. Und da ist deutlich gewesen, auch schon vorher, nur habe ich das dann mehr aus der Ferne über YouTube und so konsumiert, war völlig klar, dass also aus den Ländern, aus denen diese Leute kommen, natürlich ein eingebautes Interesse da ist. Und wie man dann sieht, in New York ist es auch normaler. Viele Medien haben Mitarbeiter, freie Mitarbeiter, feste Mitarbeiter in New York sowieso für alles Mögliche. Und wenn dann eben so ein Termin ansteht, dann wird jemand halt gefragt, kannst du nicht das coveren und dahingehen? Und ja, ich würde sagen, es ist ein mittelgroßes Interesse für das, was wir ja eigentlich noch erwähnen sollten, nämlich eine ganz heftige Gerichtssch, eine heftige Haftstrafe für Ruwan Andrell Naputh, nämlich neun Jahre Gefängnis.
Genau, die Staatsanwaltschaft hatte 20 Jahre gefordert, daraus sind dann neun geworden. Ich habe viel darüber gelesen, dass diese Strafe auch eine abschreckende Wirkung haben sollte. Würdest du dem als direkter Prozessbeobachter zustimmen?
Na ja, also wie bei so vielen Dingen im Leben, wenn man nicht erwischt wird, wird man auch nicht bestraft und viele Menschen, die etwas tun, was nicht erlaubt ist oder was verboten ist, werden sich vor allen Dingen immer mit der Frage beschäftigen, wie kann ich das so tun, dass es niemand merkt. Und ich glaube, das ist am Ende das Kernproblem, dass man eben in diesen Organisationen nach wie vor unheimlich viel verschleiern kann und unheimlich rumdeichseln kann. Und dazu kommt noch was ganz anderes, wenn ich mal kurz überleiten darf. Das Mysterium dieses einen Verfahrens gegen Naputh ist nicht gelöst worden. Juan Andrés Naputh ist einer der reichsten Männer in Paraguay. Der brauchte keine 25 Millionen Dollar für irgendeinen Lebensstil, den er sich hätte gönnen wollen. Der hatte also keine klassische finanzielle oder finanziell geprägte Motivationslage. Das Problem, warum wissen wir nicht, was er denn da jetzt getrieben hat, sieht so aus, das ist reine juristische Mathematik. Also er wird angeklagt und er wehrt sich einfach nur, indem er sagt, nein, ist alles falsch. Aber er muss selber nicht aussagen, er muss selber keine Zeugen aufrufen. Das heißt, wir haben einen so einseitigen Prozess. Die Geschworenen bekommen halt nur das Material von der einen Seite, von der Staatsanwaltschaft vorgelegt und die Zeugenaussagen. Natürlich wurde innerhalb der Beweisaufnahme versucht, seitens der Verteidigung von Naputh bestimmte Aspekte zu erschüttern und zu infrage zu ziehen. Aber da das Urteil dann festliegt, nämlich schuldig, in dem Fall in drei Fällen, ist das alles durch. Das Thema ist durch und die Frage ist jetzt nur noch, weil so arbeitet das System, was für eine Strafe muss man jetzt verhängen, um das Urteil entsprechend zu würdigen im Kontext dieser vielen Angeklagten, mit unterschiedlichen Graden an kriminellen Handeln und Bereitschaft zu kooperieren und so weiter und so weiter. Ich würde sagen, es ist abschreckend, wenn sich jemand so etwas vornimmt, dann wieder erwartet und erwischt wird und einen Prozess bekommt. Wahrscheinlich ist es besser, zu kooperieren, weil das hat automatisch die Folge, dass die Strafe geringer ausfällt. Und die Spekulation meinerseits, wahrscheinlich um die drei Jahre oder so, vier Jahre, wäre damit fertig gewesen. Aber ich hoffe, das kommt rüber. Also die Frage ist nicht geklärt worden. Und die Richterin hat auch in ihrer Begründung da ein bisschen rumgekaut und kam dann zu der Feststellung, naja, es muss sich um eine Form von Greed, also Gier, gehandelt haben. Aber sie konnte das natürlich auch nicht richtig erklären. Und auch an diesem Punkt kommen auch keine Interviews mehr, dass man noch mal sagt. Erzähl uns doch jetzt mal wirklich, was wolltest du? Also sind wir mit dem Problem alleine gelassen. Wie wird jemand in diesem Kontext kriminell, der es nicht nötig hat?
Absolut, also bei weitem nicht nötig. Also Juan Anquil Naput war von 2007 bis 2014 Vorsitzender des Paraguayanischen Fußballverbandes. 2015 war er einer der FIFA-Vizepräsidenten und war Vorsitzender, also Präsident des Südamerikanischen Fußballverbandes von 2014 bis 2015. Das waren ebenso seine Funktionen. Und in diesen Funktionen hat er Millionen von Bestechungsgeldern angenommen. Du hast vorhin die Zahl 25 genannt. Ist das dann auch das, worauf man ihn im Prozess festgenagelt hat? Waren das die nachgewiesenen Zahlungen?
Na ja, schon. Aber es wird dann immer so ein bisschen hier und her gerechnet. Also rein nach der Rechtsmathematik konnte man ihm als Teil dieser Verschwörung, das hatten die Geschworenen ja gesagt, er war Teil einer Verschwörung, zur Lasten der amerikanischen Gesetze, zur Lasten von Organisationen wie Condebol. Da gibt es eine Zahl, die ist 150 Millionen Dollar. Die Summe, die man so gehört hat. Also das ist alles, was im Laufe der Ermittlungen herausgekommen ist. Wie viel Geld ist da wirklich in schwarzen Kassen, schwarzen Kanälen abgewandert? Wenn man diese Zahl im Rahmen der Vorschriften, die es da gibt, der Regularien, die es gibt, nimmt, wäre der Mann für lebenslänglich weggesteckt worden. Das fand auch die Richterin für einfach komplett daneben und hat also eine neue Kalkulation aufgemacht. Und da spielte dann eben mehr die Rolle, also was hatte er selber für sich haben wollen. Das war also ein richtiger Plan, dass er im Laufe der Jahre 25 Millionen zugesteckt bekommen würde. Dann gab es die nächste Zahl, das Geld, was er tatsächlich wohl bekommen hat, das sind also über drei Millionen und das dann eben noch abgeglichen mit der Frage, wie hat er eigentlich da gearbeitet. Und da war ein interessantes Detail. Er hat also versucht zu verschleiern, dass er das Geld bekommen hat und dachte, das Beste ist eben, das Geld über das Bankenwesen bis nach Buenos Aires zu transferieren und es dort dann in Bargeld umzuwandeln mit den kleinere Transchen und dann mit dem Bargeld über die Grenze nach Paraguay zu gehen. Und das ist nach dem Rechtsverständnis der Amerikaner, ist das eben ein strafverschärfender Aspekt. Und dann kam noch dazu, dass er eben einen Computer hatte wegbringen lassen, nachdem er bereits wusste, eine Anordnung bekommen hatte, doch bitte schön kein Beweismaterial verschwinden zu lassen. Und dann wurde hin und her geredet, ja also was war da auf dem Computer drauf? Es war nicht ganz klar. Aber allein die Tatsache, dass er also in einer Phase, in der ihm hätte klar sein müssen, hey hallo, nix mehr hier mit weg verstecken oder so, dass er sich darüberhin weggesetzt hat. Das war eine eigene Geschichte, um die Strafe nochmal wieder nach oben zu ziehen.
Also fassen wir kurz zusammen, wir haben hier einen sehr, sehr reichen Einwohner Paraguay, der in hohen Fußballämtern war, im südamerikanischen Fußball und in dieser Zeit eben 3,3 Millionen US-Dollar definitiv bekommen hat und die Zahlen, die du genannt hast, die da im Umlauf waren 25 Millionen US-Dollar bis hin zu 150 Millionen, wenn man das ganze Netzwerk aufdeckt, zeigt, wie viel Geld er an Bestechungsgeldern, Schmiergeldern entgegengenommen hat, um die Dimensionen nochmal zu verdeutlichen, das mussten wir im Tribünengespräch des FIFA-Prozesses auch die ganze Zeit machen, aber es ist einfach unglaublich, wenn man sich einfach nochmal diese Zahlen vor Augen ruft und bei ihm kommt nochmal dieses psychologische Mysterium dazu, das macht ihn dann fast noch interessanter, er hätte es ja nicht mal gebraucht. Es war nicht so, dass er sich aus einer Armut heraus gekauft hat und ein Lebensstil finanziert hat, den er sonst nicht halten hätte können, sondern er hätte es eben nicht gebraucht. Das war Juan Andrés Naput und dadurch, dass er nicht kooperiert hat und auch erst 60 Jahre alt ist, und das ist dann eben ein Unterschied zum nächsten, über den ich gleich mit dir sprechen möchte, gab es dann eben diese neun Jahre Haft und er musste eine Million US-Dollar Geldstrafe zahlen und die 3,3 Millionen US-Dollar auch überweisen. Bis November muss er das getan haben. Das werden wir dann mitbekommen. Und damit könnten wir aber dann eigentlich über den zweiten noch sprechen, nämlich José Maria Marín, den Präsident des brasilianischen Fußballverbandes zwischen 2012 und 2015 und natürlich auch Mitglied diverser FIFA-Komitees. Kannst du mal kurz schildern, mit wem wir es da zu tun haben?
Ja, mit jemandem, der in dem Fall auch eine politische Karriere hinter sich hatte. Er war mal Gouverneur, ich glaube, das nennt man einen Bundesstaat in Brasilien, bin jetzt nicht ganz sicher, dann ist er auch Paulo. Und der immer wieder mal eine Rolle gespielt hat im brasilianischen Fußballverband, jetzt sogar noch zum Schluss, weil die mussten irgendwann mal, weil dauernd so Leute wie Teixeira und andere aus dem Rennen genommen werden mussten, mussten sie immer wieder jemand anderen finden. Und dann war er derjenige, der hat sich wohl nicht so schnell genug weggeduckt. Und dann hat er aber auch Spaß gefunden an dieser neuen Phase der Arbeit, wo man eben auch für sich selber was rausholen konnte. Auch der Mann hatte ja Immobilien in Amerika, also zumindest wissen wir von einer Wohnung im Trump Tower, wo er auch die letzte Zeit bis zum Prozess verbracht hat unter Hausarrest. Dann wurde er nach der Verurteilung, nach dem Schuldspruch, wurde er mit Napoo zusammen ins Gefängnis gesteckt, nach dem Motto Fluchtgefahr. Wir lassen niemanden mehr auf Kaution raus. Und es wurde ihm insgesamt eben etwas weniger kriminelles Verhalten, also in der Abwägung, das ist ja für ihn nicht ganz einfach. Die Richterin hat ihm also etwas weniger zu gebilligt. Und als ganz großen Pluspunkt sein Alter. Also jemanden mit 86 dann so lange wegzuschließen, das findet man in Amerika, wo man ja doch sehr für drakonische Strafen ist, das findet man dann auch nicht korrekt.
Also zehn Jahre hat er die Staatsanwaltschaft gefordert, da wäre er dann mit 96 wieder rausgekommen, wenn das denn nicht würde.
Nun muss man vielleicht noch eines dazusagen, beide werden Berufung einlegen und versuchen, da noch was rauszuholen. Das ändert erst mal nichts an den Gegebenheiten. Also jetzt sind sie beide verurteilt, das heißt, sie sind eigentlich mehr in U-Haft, was auch nicht so schick ist im Vergleich zu normaler Strafhaft. Aber jetzt sind sie wirklich die Marionetten in einer Organisation, nämlich der Bundesgefängnisverwaltung, die sie auch dahin stecken kann, wo sie wollen. Es gibt auch unterschiedlich schwere Formen der Gefängnisse, wo auch die Besucher leichter reinkommen oder so. Das liegt jetzt alles in den Händen dieser Verwaltung. Und für beide, die jetzt nach einem Prozess verurteilt worden sind, also nicht gestanden haben, bleibt natürlich die Berufung eine Option und das werden sie auch beide machen. Und man kann auch spekulieren, dass die Strafen dann ein bisschen noch reduziert werden. Das passiert schon mal. Aber die Rechtsanwälte, aber auch die Richterin, die haben solche Dinge immer im Auge. Die wissen ganz genau, wie sie sich verhalten müssen in einem Prozess, damit Dinge nicht ohne Weiteres in der Berufungsinstanz komplett neu aufgeribbelt werden. Also man versucht eher, so was, wie es auch in Deutschland üblich ist, zumindest im Strafverfahren, wo es die sogenannte Revision gibt, da wird nur darüber verhandelt in der nächsten Instanz, ob irgendwas falsch gelaufen ist in dem Verfahren. Und es wird nicht nochmal das Verfahren völlig neu aufgegriffen. Das ist hier anders. Es wird hier wahrscheinlich, die Berufungsinstanz lehnt das einfach ab und sagt, danke, ich sehe hier keine Gründe, wird das komplett nochmal neu aufgreifen können. Das heißt, es kann sein, dass wir alle noch mal... Ich denke, wir haben ja dann eigentlich alles erzählt, also bis auf das, was immer da rauskommt. Und das heißt nur, dass wir noch mehr, noch länger mit diesem Kram zu tun haben, als wir es eh schon haben. Und wir haben ja beim Tribünengespräch auch schon darüber gesprochen, wir kommen ja jetzt in diese Phase, wo die übrigen Angeklagten, die sich für schuldig erklärt haben, jetzt mit Strafen bedacht werden. Und es wird interessant sein, wir haben jetzt so ein Gerüst im Grunde, wie werden Straftaten bewertet. Also niemand von denen, die jetzt an die Reihe kommen, wird auch nur annähernd so viele Jahre verknackt wie Naputh. Das wird sich jetzt alles in dem Bereich, würde ich mal schätzen, zwischen drei und maximal fünf Jahren oder so abspielen.
Selbst wenn man Jack Warner habhaft würde?
Ja, das muss man komplett rausnehmen. Wenn man ihn hätte, dann ist die nächste Frage, kooperiert er oder setzt er sich auch da hin und sagt, ihr seid dran, ich hab keinen Bock. Dann kommt das, das kann ein Faktor sein. Wenn er kooperiert, wird er vermutlich genauso behandelt wie die anderen Geständigen. Und jemand wie Jeffrey Webb ist so ein bisschen, das habe ich jetzt auch besser verstanden als in der ersten Phase der ganzen Geschichte. Jeffrey Webb ist ja jemand, der schon Warner kannte, bevor er sein Nachfolger wurde, und der als Reformer angetreten ist. Und der so tat, als würde er jetzt alles aufräumen, das wird besser und sauber.
Er hat eine große Show gefahren. Blatter hat ihn ja schon als sein potenziell Nachfolger versucht zu positionieren, kurz bevor dann alles aufflog.
Aber auch dieses Verhalten gegenüber der internen Situation innerhalb der Fußballorganisation wird ihm als extra schlecht angerechnet werden, weil er hat diesen Betrugsaspekt, er hat das noch raffinierter vorangetrieben als vielleicht einer, der da reingetappert ist und gesagt hat, okay, ihr habt so viel Geld, okay, dann gibt mir mal was, also das, ich glaube, Web ist im Moment so die nächste Hausnummer. Da wird auch dauernd verschoben, wann der dran ist mit seiner Strafe. Ich weiß nicht, ob der noch hofft, dass er sich was günstiger was rausholen kann. Also warte mal, ich gucke mal gerade nach, auf der Liste ist er jetzt dran für den 7. März 2019 und der hätte schon eine Strafe haben können, denn den ersten Termin war schon für 2017 mal angesetzt, ist also jetzt dauernd verschoben worden. 7. März 2019. Und ich spekuliere jetzt nur, ich weiß es nicht, weil keiner redet mit mir darüber, vielleicht steckt darin noch dieses Ding, dass sie hoffen, dass sie Warner ausgeliefert bekommen, bis dahin und dass sie dann durch Web-Aussagen Warner besser nageln können. Und das Web dann sich dadurch mehr Bonuspunkte erwirtschaften kann. Aber ich spekuliere nur.
Ja, also ganz kurz noch zur Einordnung, Jack Warner war der Präsident des CONCACAF, das ist der Verband, in dem unter anderem sein Heimatland Trinidad und Tobago mit dabei ist, wo er jetzt auch immer noch ist und sich einer Auslieferung verweigert. Er war auch dort mal Minister und gilt so ein bisschen als der Korruptionsarchitekt, neben anderen großen Namen, denen man bisher nichts nachweisen kann. Also wir haben auch über den Bezug zu Blatter im Tribünengespräch ausführlich gesprochen. Jeffrey Webb ist dann sein Nachfolger, der mit großen Ambitionen gestartet ist und ebenso großen Partys. Und dann kam heraus, er war sogar noch gieriger als Jack Warner himself. Das heißt, das sind die beiden Personen, um die es hier geht. Also José María Marín vier Jahre Gefängnis bekommen, unter anderem wegen seines Alters und weil er kooperiert hat und nichtsdestotwas. Stimmt, er hat auch nicht kooperiert. Stimmt, hast recht.
Er und Naputh waren die zwei Einzigen, die wirklich im Rahmen eines normalen Prozesses dann für schuldig befunden wurden. Sie haben also dem Staat ihren Aufwand mit aufgebürdet, um sie überführen zu können. Wobei man sich nicht darüber beschweren sollte. Es ist ja das gute Recht von Leuten, sich zu verteidigen und Sachen abzustreiten. Und das Rechtsprinzip gilt, also man muss ihnen das, wie wir hier in Amerika sagen, beyond reasonable doubt, also jenseits allen vernunft definierbaren Zweifels, muss man ihnen das nachweisen, dass sie gegen die Gesetze verstoßen haben. Also das kann man ja jetzt nicht dann gegen sie wenden, aber wenn es um die Strafzumessung geht, wird das natürlich durchaus in die Wachstelle geworfen.
Ja. Die Richterin nannte ihn und seine Mitverschwore The Very Cancer on the Sport, also den Krebs des Sportes, den sie angeblich liebten. Das ist die direkte deutsche Übersetzung dessen, was sie da gesagt hat. Die Urteilsbegründungen sind insofern wichtig, weil man daraus so ein bisschen Rückschlüsse versucht zu ziehen, ob eventuell an einem späteren Punkt gesagt werden könnte, es war das ganze System FIFA, was diese Korruption nicht nur geduldet hat, sondern befördert hat. Und damit würden dann eine ganze Reihe von anderen Möglichkeiten juristischer Art nochmal offen werden. Deswegen sind die Urteilsbegründungen gerade sehr wichtig. Damit wir noch einmal kurz darüber gesprochen haben, obwohl es da jetzt keinen Neunstand gibt, Manuel Burger, der FA-Präsident des Peruanischen Fußballverbandes von zwölf Jahren, von 2002 bis 2014, und auch Mitglied eines wichtigen FIFA-Komitees, der wurde freigesprochen und das schon vor einer Weile, also das hat die Jury entschieden, so wie es in den USA Standard ist. Wir haben jetzt dann die Strafen für die beiden Schuldigesprochenen bekommen. Der ist unter anderem dadurch aufgefallen, dass er beim Auftritt eines Kronzeugen sich mehrmals mit der Hand über die Gurgel gefahren ist. Im Nachhinein hieß es dann, er hätte eine Hautkrankheit, haben seine Verteidiger gesagt. Viele und unter anderem auch der Kronzeuge, der unter Tränen zusammengebrochen ist, haben das aber als Drohung verstanden. Ich vermute, über ihn wird jetzt kein Wort mehr verloren worden sein, denn da ist ja das Urteil schon gefällt worden und zwar positiver Natur. Aber kannst du das mit dem, was wir jetzt über die Strafen der anderen beiden wissen, besser einordnen als vorher? Ich war etwas irritiert, dass Burger in Anführungszeichen davon gekommen ist, obwohl nach allem, was ich gelesen habe, da schon sehr viel Beweise vorlagen. Es konnte nur ganz, also vielleicht hat er sich schlauer verhalten. Das scheint so mein aktuelles Fazit.
Das ist möglich. Also ich kann das selber jetzt auch nicht viel besser beurteilen, weil man hätte schon bei den Geschworenen mit dabei sein müssen, um zu erkennen, was diskutieren die da, nach was für Maßstimmen gehen die da vor. Und wenn halt die Beweislage nicht so zwingend ist wie bei anderen, kann es sein, dass auch eine Jury dann manchmal sagt, okay, dann lassen wir den jetzt laufen. Weil im Prinzip wird ja nun auch dem Heerenprinzip Recht getan, Recht getan, wenn man wirklich alles aufdeckt, wenn man auch Leute zu fassen bekommt und auch eben bestimmte Leute ja auch dann schuldig spricht. Also ich glaube, das ist okay und die Sache mit dieser Drohung, mit dieser versteckten Drohung ist eben auch nicht deutlich genug nachgewiesen worden und das muss man dann auch akzeptieren. Also ich bin da auch ein Freund davon, zu sagen, also man kann jetzt nicht nur, weil bestimmte Verdachtsmomente da sind, wenn man die nicht erhärten kann, dann kann man nicht zwingend jemanden dafür verantwortlich machen. Dabei kommen auch Leute durch, die was angestellt haben, das ist so, aber ich glaube, das System zeigt doch im Schnitt, dass das nur in wenigen Fällen der Fall ist. Also selbst El Capone kriegt man ja irgendwann mal mit einer Steuergeschichte.
Genau, auch über Steuern. So fing das ja auch alles mit dem FIFA-Prozess. Unter anderem an einer der wesentlichen Involvierten war ein Agent der Steuerbehörde, der festgestellt hat, dass Chuck Blaser, unser Kronzeuge, den wir jetzt schon zweimal erwähnt haben, noch schon seit Jahren keinerlei Steuererklärungen abgegeben hat und sich aber ein luxuriöses Leben im Trump Tower leisten konnte. Das war einer der beiden Anstöße, alles andere im Tribünengespräch. Lass uns das mal ganz kurz einordnen jetzt. Also wir wussten vorher schon, dass es zwei Schuldsprüche gäbe. Jetzt kennen wir Strafen und wir haben die jetzt auch schon eingeordnet und die sind vor allem die gegenüber Naputh sehr drakonisch. Was glaubst du denn, wird sich jetzt in Bezug auf die FIFA selbst tun, die ja auch in diesen Prozessen jetzt eher als Opfer agieren kann und möchte aus ihrer Sicht heraus? Gibt es da irgendwelche Ansatzpunkte zu erkennen, was das für Auswirkungen hat?
Also ich glaube, dass die FIFA selbst Schwierigkeiten haben dürfte, das durchzusetzen, dass sie, was diesen Komplex angeht, mit diesen Beteiligten und diesen Geschäften, da ist die bei Veranstaltungen wie der Copa America oder Copa Libertadores oder so, da ist die FIFA ja nicht wirklich involviert. Das heißt, da wurden andere Organisationen, sprich Konföderationen geschädigt und natürlich hätten die einen Anspruch darauf, auf die Schadensersatzsummen. Trotzdem ist natürlich die FIFA immer bereit, sich da irgendwie zu inszenieren und so zu tun, als hätte sie da darunter gelitten. Wobei die FIFA oder die Gremien der FIFA und die Leute im Rahmen dieser Organisationsstruktur FIFA alles getan haben, um nicht erwischt zu werden. Und die haben sich dann auch eben am Rande von FIFA-Terminen getroffen, also die Sachen, die rund um Grund Donau gelaufen sind, jemanden, dessen Namen wir jetzt nicht groß erklären müssen, aber ein ehemaliger argentinischer Funktionär, der nun auch schon länger tot ist und der als Chef der Finanzkommission unglaublich viel Einfluss hatte darauf, was da gelaufen ist und sich die Taschen vorher gemacht hat. Das lief alles unter dem, also diese Leute waren mächtig, weil sie in der FIFA-Ebene, Exekutivkomitee, wie das damals hieß, oder in den Kommissionen eine Rolle gespielt haben, weil sie in Ethikkommissionen saßen, in denen sie alles Mögliche plattbügeln konnten. Da ist die FIFA durchaus als Plattform oder als Player, spielt sie eine Rolle, aber nicht unbedingt als geschädigt, weil die FIFA richtet ja gerade mal Fußballweltmeisterschaften aus. Und diese Veranstaltung, dazu gibt es bisher, zumindest aus dem Material, das wir kennen, gibt es keine Hinweise darauf, dass die zum Beispiel die Fernsehverträge bezogen auf Weltmeisterschaften, dass die irgendwie verschoben worden sind. Wir wissen über Bestechungsversuche in Sachen Ausrichtung von WM. Aber das ist auch ein Thema, das ja hier nicht mit abgehandelt wird. Also es wird interessant sein zu sehen, hat die FIFA selber irgendetwas aufzubieten, um zu sagen, wir brauchen Millionen aus dem Topf? Oder wird die FIFA vielleicht von Frau Chen, von Pamela Chen zurückgepfiffen?
Der Richterin.
Weil Kolinas Erben noch nicht so weit sind, das zu machen. Das könnten die ja, die FIFA, zurückpfeifen.
Die würden das auch mit einer ordentlichen Vehemenz tun. Es gibt noch einen Nebenstreng, der mit dem Prozess nichts zu tun hat, aber ich glaube, verdeutlicht, wie die Uhren in der Schweiz, in der FIFA-Zentrale ticken. Es gibt nämlich einen neuen FIFA-Ethikodex, auf den wurde lange gewartet. Ich fasse mal drei wichtige Dinge daraus zusammen. Das Wort Korruption kommt nicht mehr vor. Es gibt jetzt Fristen für die Aufdeckung von Korruption und Bestechungsfällen. Interessanterweise ist die Frist auf zehn Jahre gesetzt. Das gibt es in anderen Rechtsformen auch. Das ist nichts Neues. Es ist aber insofern wichtig, weil alles rund um Bestechungsvorwürfe, rund um das Qatar-Turnier 2022, damit interessanterweise dann wahrscheinlich sehr bald oder schon jetzt verjährt wäre. Und es gibt eine neue Verleumdungsklausel, die automatische Geldstrafen nach sich zieht, sobald jemand aus der FIFA, ich nenne sie jetzt mal Familie in Anführungszeichen, seine Geheimhaltungspflicht verletzt. Also ein Ethikkod, der im Wesentlichen, ja, unethische Maßnahmen erleichtert, sogar freistellt, wenn sie eine gewisse Frist abgelaufen haben und Bisseblauer noch bestrafen will. Das ging mir fast ein bisschen unter in der Berichterstattung, zumindest hier in Deutschland. Das war Mitte August, kam da raus. Hast du irgendwelche Hoffnung, dass sich da etwas ändert in dieser Organisation?
Ne, also mir kommt Gianni Infantino so vor wie auch andere, die angetreten sind mit großen Worten und Versprechungen und die dann in dem Moment ja nun Mehrheiten finden mussten, um gewählt zu werden. Und es gab ja auch Gegenkandidaten, als Infantino antrat. Und einer von denen aus Bahrain wäre sicherlich nicht die attraktivere Alternative gewesen. Aber wie dem auch sei, ich glaube, Infantino hat gelernt bei der UEFA, wie man macht, konzentriert und auf sich selber so zieht, dass man bestimmte Hebel in die Hand bekommt. Für mich ist das das Erdogan-Modell oder jede andere Form von autokratischer Organisationsform. Es ist einfach nur ein weiterer Beweis dafür, dass die Lüge, dass wir hier von einer von unten nach oben regierten Konstruktion reden, das ist einfach Nonsens. Das ist Seilschaft, Puster, Puster-Kategorie und darüber muss man sich jetzt keine Illusionen machen. Manche haben sich vielleicht Illusionen gemacht, ich gehöre jetzt nicht dazu. Die Frage ist dann natürlich für den Medienmenschen, wie gehst du mit sowas um? Das ist so vergleichbar mit dem, was man den Journalisten immer vorhält, im Moment, wenn es um Trump geht zum Beispiel. Wie geht man mit so jemandem um, der ständig lügt, der ständig autokratische Tendenzen hat, der die Medien verteufelt? Stichwort AfD. Wie geht man mit diesen Leuten um, die eine ähnliche strategische Denke entwickelt haben? Natürlich will ich jetzt als Journalist mich nicht einfach eindeutig hier äußern. Ich weiß es gar nicht, aber ich gehöre auch zu denen, die sich da sehr, sehr sensibel geben, nach dem Motto, wir können das nicht alles einfach mitmachen oder dulden oder so. Wir müssen wieder irgendwie den Anlass und den Weg finden, um uns so selber dazu zu stellen, dass wir sagen, okay, wir haben eine Rolle zu spielen, weil bestimmte Teile der Gesellschaft nicht funktionieren. Und das klingt jetzt nach vielen großen Worten. Ich hoffe, das ist nicht so gemeint. Es ist der Alltag einer Journalisten wie mir. Wir wollen berichten, wir wollen die Wahrheit wissen, wir wollen hinter den Kulissen einen Einblick gewinnen, damit das, was man uns vorspielt, auf die bestmögliche Weise entkleidet werden kann.
Und immer wieder nachfragen, nachfragen, nachfragen. Also es ist eine romantische Vorstellung, dass irgendwann mal die Verbände noch deutlicher in Opposition gehen würden. Also jetzt im Falle Infantino scheint sich da ein bisschen was zusammenzubrauen, aber das kann alles noch gar nichts heißen. Er hat auch noch viele Unterstützer. Aber man muss auch wirklich diejenigen Leute, die dann zum Beispiel für den DFB da bei der FIFA sitzen, auch immer wieder damit konfrontieren. Wie finden Sie den Ethikkodex? Finden Sie, dass es ausreichend? Wie sehen Sie das? Und ja, nur so wird es funktionieren, auch wenn es immer so ein bisschen der moralisch erhobene Zeigefinger ist und man auch die Antworten immer bekommt, mit denen man auch vorher schon gerechnet hat.
Und ansonsten kann man eigentlich, wenn man nun als ganz normaler, leidenschaftlicher Fußballfan, an jetzt, sagen wir mal, die Ebene FIFA, also sprich Nationalmannschaften und Wettbewerber von Nationalmannschaften gegeneinander, wenn man da rangeht, dann kann man auch nur sagen, okay, vielleicht werdet ihr alle irgendwann mal so desillusioniert sein, dass ihr keine Lust mehr habt, euch das anzuschauen. Das wird dann geprägt sein von jedem einzelnen Land oder von den Verhältnissen in einem einzelnen Land und da ist ja der DFB gerade auf keinen besonders guten Weg.
Komm, die Mannschaft wird jetzt von den Stakeholdern erstmal analysiert, also ich bin zufrieden.
Ja, ich sag jetzt ein Foto mit Bierhoff, wo jemand schrieb, das seien jetzt die Stakeholder und dann hab ich erstmal so, das liegt natürlich daran, wie ich jetzt mit Englisch umgehe, gefragt, wo sind denn die Steaks, also nicht die Fleischsteaks, sondern die Stöckchen, die hätte ich dann auch mal gerne gesehen, dass jemand die wirklich mal in den Händen hält, was ist das eigentlich?
Das müsste ein Golfschläger sein bei dem Klientel, mit ihm sich der Ding nicht mehr hat.
Glaubst du, wir haben das ganz rund gekriegt jetzt heute oder haben wir noch was ausgelassen?
Ich glaube, den aktuell laufenden Prozess mit den Strafmaßen haben wir jetzt gut erörtert und alles andere finden die Hörerinnen und Hörern ja im Tribünengespräch. Ich glaube allerdings, Jürgen, dass das nicht das letzte Gespräch zwischen uns beiden geblieben sein wird zu diesem Überkomplex, der je tiefer man einsteigt, desto verwirrender wird es. Also seitdem ich Ken Bensinger, dem Autor eines dieses sehr guten Buches zum FIFA-Prozess, auf Twitter folge, habe ich schon wieder so viele neue Namen kennengelernt und müsste eigentlich jetzt meine eigene Wikipedia nur dafür anlegen. Ich glaube, das Thema wird uns noch lange begleiten und ich bin froh, dass ich da jemanden jenseits des großen Teiches habe, den ich da immer mal wieder anrufen kann.
Ja, und vielleicht passt das noch hier hin. Also ich habe jetzt gerade eine Geschichte über Doping im Eishockey gemacht, mache jetzt gerade gerade Vorgeschichten über Kepernick, über Trump und die NFL und so was. Ich bin eigentlich im Rückblick ganz überrascht, wie ich als Journalist in die Lage gekommen bin, über nur solche Sachen zu schreiben.
Nur die gute Launenthemen hat er sich rausgepickt, Jürgen.
Also als ob man sowas quasi auf der Journalisten-Schule schon das Fach gegeben, das Spezialfach gegeben hätte, Journalismus im Sport mit diesen kritischen Ansprüchen und diesen schlechten Nachrichten. Ich erinnere mich nicht daran, dass das irgendwann vor vielen Jahren so uns beschäftigt haben könnte. Plötzlich gehöre ich zu denen, die das also dauernd liefern. Ich bin aber ganz froh darüber, dass ich das machen kann, weil ich glaube, es ist verdienstvoller und man lernt auch selber mehr dabei, als wenn man nur hinter irgendwelchen Fußball- oder Sportstars hinterherläuft und die einen heimlich anhimmelt oder so, das vielleicht Autogramme haben will. Etwas, das mich auch sehr verstört. Weil es gibt ja doch mehr und mehr Kollegen, die sich nun auf Instagram mit Fotos zeigen, wo sie neben dem Star stehen und so tun, als hätten sie jetzt irgendetwas geleistet, dass sie jetzt da stehen könnten.
Ja, wollen wir nicht in Kollegen-Shelter ausarten? Da hatten wir schon einen Exkurs, das weiß ich noch, glaube ich, nach anderthalb Stunden im Tribüngespräch, als wir noch bei einem von vier Gliederungspunkten waren, sagtest du, erlaube mir diesen kurzen Einschub und dann haben wir eine halbe Stunde, glaube ich, über dieses Thema diskutiert. Aber weißt du, es ist eine Frage des Geistes. Ich finde es auch einfach spannend, mir über die Fragen Gedanken zu machen, die nicht so häufig gestellt werden und deren Antworten ich nicht so erwartbar finde. Und so tickst du wahrscheinlich auch. Und deswegen danke ich dir sehr herzlich, dass du auch heute dir wieder die Zeit genommen hast. Jürgen Kalwa, at American Arena, auf Twitter. Möge er noch viele weite Twitter-Follower durch diesen Kurzpass bekommen. Mal gucken, ob das noch mal ein anderes Klientel ist. Danke dir, Jürgen, dass du dir mal wieder Zeit genommen hast.
Nein, ich danke dir und danke für deine Arbeit, weil ich weiß, dass du sehr viel reinsteckst. Es gilt. Es muss gesagt werden, wenigstens in einer moderaten Dosis.
Ja, du hast es schon im Tribünengespräch gesagt. Nein, nein, nein, nein, nein. Danke, danke, danke. Und ich bekomme ja auch genügend Komplimente dafür und auch es gibt ganz viele Rasenfunk-Supporterinnen und Supporter. Das heißt, finanziell scheint der Rasenfunk-Seiter WM auf einem sehr, sehr guten Weg zu sein. Und das ist ja alles, was ich möchte. Und dann ist es aber auch nicht mehr hier pure Selbstlosigkeit, sich in Themen reinzuwirken. Jetzt ist es einfach mein Job, meine Aufgabe. Danke dir, Jürgen. Danke euch, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Lasst uns wie immer gerne Feedback da. Ihr habt gehört, wie sehr es uns freut im Forum unter mitmachen.rasenfunk.de und natürlich auf Twitter. Da bin ich der Gehnetzer. Und Jürgen ist als at American Arena unterwegs. Und dann hören wir uns wieder in der nächsten Schlusskonferenz, dem nächsten Tribünengespräch oder dem nächsten Kurspass hier im Rasenfunk. Wenn ihr uns unterstützen wollt, rasenfunk.de unterstützen. Danke euch. Bis bald mal wieder. Macht's gut.